Regardless of whether you are looking for your first job or want to change the one  you have,...
...these tips will help you get your dream job.
Tips for landing your dream job.
One, determine which aspects of your job that you like ...
...and then find a way to do more of whatever that is.
Two, learn from the best in your office.
Three, determine your career signature.
If you had to write down one statement that would encompass who you are or want to be...
...professionally and personally, what would it say?
Four, recognize which aspects of your work you can and cannot control.
Write down  the things that stress you out at work.
Cross out and stop spending energy on the ones over which you have no control.
Five, do the job above your current position.
Becoming familiar with that role makes you an obvious choice for future promotion.
Six, accomplish projects at work that directly affect your resume.
When taking on new projects,...
...try to select and quantify the results and add them to your resume.
Seven, cultivate friendships at work.
You'll benefit personally and professionally from the time you invest in getting to know them.
Eight, see the big and little pictures.
What is your overall vision for your professional life?
Now what are the small daily steps that will get you there?
Nine, remember none of the above suggestions will work if your career isn't aligned with your true interests,...
...personality and natural abilities.